welcome to Sandler's honest book reviews
the book that I'm reviewing today you
see it right here it's meditations on
self-discipline and failure stoic
exercise for mental fitness by William
pariah low disclaimer from the very
beginning this is a review copy that was
sent to me by the author it's it's one
that I enjoyed quite a bit
William is indeed a a colleague of mine
connected to me through the you know
stoic community so it's natural that the
book came my way but I just want
everyone to know some of the
circumstances so he asked me to provide
a review of it and Sandler's honest book
reviews I always give you the good and
the bad what I can tell you is that
there's a lot of good in this book it's
it's one that I definitely recommend
getting if you're a certain type of
reader and if you've got certain
interests and that's what I'll talk
about next
right so let's talk about the structure
the style a little bit of summary of
this this book the way it's structured
is a bit old-fashioned it's divided into
thirty books really they could just be
called chapters but I understand what
the point of that is each of them is
supposed to be like a book in in an
ancient text each of them is divided
further into some chapters numbered
usually about a paragraph or so long and
in style I would say that this is really
what we could say it's it's in the
hortatory or the diatribe genre because
each of these chapters is either they're
all addressing the reader and they're
either telling the reader what to do or
in some cases saying things that the
reader probably doesn't want to hear or
explaining something but doing so in a
fairly brief way so so it very much is
along the lines of something like a old
fashioned diatribe it's written I would
say for the general to well educated
reader it doesn't actually presuppose
that you know an awful lot about stoic
philosophy in order to get something out
of it in order to understand it and
William actually begins the book in the
preface or the the the introduction
actually by saying look you know this is
a bit difficult in terms of the writing
but you're just gonna have to grow into
it understandably so he says I'm not
going to try to explain it as to the
average twelve-year-old because you're
not an average twelve-year-old so you
may want to leave the book on the shelf
for a few more years I think it's
perfectly fair point what is the book
really about so I mean the title is
meditations on self-discipline and
failure and I think that it's an
interesting idea that the discussion of
failure it's really an attempt to try to
provide a stoic perspective of sorts on
all sorts of things in contemporary life
to provide advice that might be useful
to somebody so if you're looking for
something that I would say is at least
in most respects authentically stoic and
Jen you know genuinely is the product of
somebody who's read the stomach text
says has assimilated them has thought a
lot about them that I think this is a
good book for you I'd recommend it
what are some of the key ideas of this
book that I think will help you make a
decision whether you want to get
yourself a copy of it or not so I'm
gonna run through these in kind of a
bullet point fashion not dwelling on
them very long but just telling you what
some of the the key themes and doctrines
are so it's very clear that this is a
book for the self-reliant or the person
who wants to be talked into being
self-reliant there's a strong suspicion
of politics as largely theater this
comes up in a number of places I would
say one of the key messages of the book
over and over again is that we should
toughen up face reality don't be weak we
should take responsibility for our vices
for the things that are wrong with us
and work on the virtues I don't want to
give the impression that it that it's
totally uncompromising or that it's it's
a you know sort of writing everybody off
it I think it meets the reader who does
want to work on their their issues one
of the really interesting aspects of a
book is this discussion of well what do
we do with our failures because we're
going to be failing an awful lot I think
this is totally correct about the the
stoic path and about in a moral
philosophy applied to life in general
we're always gonna have to figure out
how to pick ourselves up and and move on
from our failures and what can we learn
from them another key idea is that we
were given a lot of things that the
Stoics called externals and indifference
like our financial means right or income
our relationships with other people our
social status all of those things we
ought to use prudently without getting
too attached to them so that we we get
very upset when things don't go our way
with them another thing that I think is
quite interesting so that there is a
strong emphasis on appreciation and
gratitude for what it is that we do have
which i think is a positive mess
of the book don't expect or feel
entitled to anything from anyone it's
taking the sort of epic TD and what is
in our power what's not in our power you
know focus just on what's in your power
to about as much of an extreme as it can
he he also talks about anger and temper
and forgiveness that comes up quite
quite frequently the need to restrain
our anger to you know realize why we
lost our temper to forgive others not to
hold grudges and then I think another
really interesting aspect of the book is
he talks about getting small and this
ties in with that issue of externals
it's sort of the opposite of the body
builders get big the body builder is
focused primarily just on the body right
which is an external from the stoic
perspective william clearly is somebody
who is interested in exercise and a
Cesis but the idea is to get ourselves
small to pare ourselves down to the
minimum and you know to to that in that
way the Stoics thought we could free
ourselves we could keep ourselves from
being as they called it hindered and we
could concentrate on what's really
valuable in life the last theme that I
want to hit on again very typically
Orthodox stoic idea life is short
things are passing away we should put
things in the proper perspective so that
we can in fact act appropriately with
the the things that we do have
I'd like to say a little bit about what
I particularly liked about the book and
what I think are some real positive
aspects to it these might not be things
that appeal to everybody but but you
know some of this has to do with our own
personal characters and temperaments so
this is this is definitely not going to
be a book that everybody is going to
like to read I enjoyed it quite a bit
but I also enjoy reading Epictetus and
the stories about the cynics so this
this kind of diatribe genre fits in well
for me I also really really liked
Williams emphasis on a lot of
contemporary issues he's he's definitely
thinking out how stoicism can apply to
our own days and times he talks a lot
about the media about contemporary
politics about things like terrorism and
crime the cult of celebrity that we have
about the abortion itself about you know
the need for meditation there's a good
sort of Irenaeus kind of a kind of
approach to matters of religion and and
God he you know he takes the stance of
well we don't really know and and even
if God doesn't exist we can still have a
you know a good moral life within this
universe a valuable life I mentioned
that that I think that there's some good
discussion here about anger and
forgiveness and also the attitude of
gratitude and I see those as in many
respects sort of typical Ciceronian and
and in some respects Sennett Seneca type
of stuff so it's not all straight out
Epictetus I think that that this is a
fairly faithful representation of
certain aspects of what stoicism has to
offer
on the whole I think this is a quite a
good book there are a few aspects of it
that I myself find problematic I think
that they're more matters of emphasis
than you know total disagreements with
anything I think that this is a good
example of a type of stoicism that maybe
veers more towards classical cynicism in
certain respects particularly in its
disengagement from the the political and
cultural spheres it's almost dismissal
of those there's also a discussion in
there about tribalism in Chapter 8 that
I myself I find a bit out of sorts with
the stoic notion of cosmopolitanism this
is the sort of thing where I think you
could you can see something like this in
for example Cicero but even Cicero
thinks that we have to you know think in
terms of the universal human race
there's also a discussion in in Chapter
9 about happiness that almost seems
rather conch in rather than stoic saying
that that happiness really isn't our
goal that that living right is is our
goal and I mean you know for the classic
Stoics and I think for contemporary
Stoics of most sorts eudaimonia living
well that's that's really happiness
that's really what the goal is but you
can't live well without living rightly
so I don't I don't think that we want to
split those apart quite so much and
there is a you know somewhat troubling
emphasis on we have to resist violence
with violence
Williams seems to say at certain points
for example in chapter 10 in chapter 24
that once somebody crosses a certain
line no no holds barred for them and
this is something I need to think about
a bit more you know how do we how do we
pose a modern nihilistic terrorism or or
you know certain kinds of criminal
activity
or you know unjust you know military
aggression how do we resist these sorts
of things as Stoics I think there's
there's a lot of discussion that still
needs to go on it can't just be well
once the line is crossed anything goes
but those are like I said I think more
matters of emphasis rather than complete
disagreements and so on the whole I
think it's a pretty good book
all right so to sum up I would say that
for most readers I would in fact
recommend this this book meditations on
self-discipline and failure stoic
exercise for mental fitness by William
for Rio Lowe I think if you have an
interest in contemporary stoicism you
may find yourself disagreeing with the
tone or with with a few of the things
that he says but but it's a good book to
have I think it belongs on a stoic
bookshelf or a virtue ethics bookshelf
or a you know I'm gonna develop myself I
don't want to say self-help but the self
development kind of bookshelf it may you
know may not appeal to all readers for
some of the reasons that that I've
mentioned it's well written very
accessible I think for most people it's
gonna make you work somewhat so it's
good stoic exercise for mental fitness
and I'm very happy that that I got to
review it it's not it's one that I'm
looking forward to finding the time to
read again down the line
you